Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say!'
Do you know what to say when you talk about where you're from?
Listen out for useful language for
talking about where you're from.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
So where are you from, Vanya?
I was born in Cambridge,
but I live in Glasgow.
I've never been to Glasgow.
What's it like?
Oh, it's wonderful.
There's always something interesting to do
and the people are really friendly.
It sounds like a nice place to live.
It is. I love it!
What about you?
Where are you from in Turkey?
I'm from Istanbul.
Oh, I love Istanbul!
I went once,
but a long time ago.
My favourite thing was baklava.
I really, really love baklava!
Today's your lucky day, Vanya.
I made it myself!
Oh!
These look delicious!
Hi!
Hi, Yuna!
Can I?
Of course!
Emir's baklava is the best.
Thank you!
You're welcome.
I love this place!
Hello again!
Mmm, that baklava looks delicious!
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for talking about where you're from?
Listen to me
and then repeat.
Where are you from?
I was born in London.
I live in Glasgow now.
What's it like?
It sounds like a nice place to live.
What about you?
I'm from Istanbul.
I love Istanbul.
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you talk about where you're from in English.
Bye for now!